THE HIGHEST SCORING QUARTER IN
THE NBA THIS SEASON HAPPENED
TONIGHT HERE AT AMERICAN
AIRLINES CENTER.
AND GAME NUMBER 56 OF THE SEASON
FOR THE MAVERICKS.
LUKA DONCIC WITH A 28 POINT
FIRST QUARTER, SURPASSING THE 25
THAT STEPH CURRY HAD IN THE GAME
AGAINST THESE LOS ANGELES
CLIPPERS IN THE FIRST WEEK OF
THE SEASON.
KELLY UBRE, AND FRED VAN VLEETS.
>> Derek: WHAT DO ZUBAC.
HE'S HAD --
>> Mark: THAT WAS NO
BIG NIGHTS, SO HAS
REMEMBER THE PLAYOFFS LAST  THI
RIGHT HERE.
>> Mark: THIS GUY RIGHT HERE IS
DOING SOME DF LATE.
AND ANOTHER BIG ONE TONIGHT.
ABSOLUTELY OUTST THIS SEASON.
HERE IS LUKASCORER.
AND TONIGHT ISFRIENDS, SOMETHI
SHOW.
OH, MY. Derek: THEY'RE CALL MEG.
PEOPLE ARE CALLING
MISSEDk: WELL THE MAVERICK
RECORD FOR POINTS